if you want to support this channel and
get cool attack on titan merge like
humanity's strongest soldier Superman
Batman Ackerman and keep calm and check
out the merch store link in the
description
[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime our program before we get
started I just want to thank you all for
over 100,000 subscribers I know that
some are most active and loyal fans here
on the channel our our attack on Titan
fans and we really love and appreciate
each and every one of you we plan on
celebrating this huge milestone with
parties on our discord server and on our
twitch so be sure to follow us on
discord and twitch if you want to take
part in this we're gonna be having voice
chat parties on discord we're gonna be
playing party games on Twitch so feel
free to join us in this video we will be
talking about the ninth and final titan
shifter the Warhammer Titan and of
course this video will contain spoilers
up to the latest chapters of the attack
on Titan manga now we've known that a
9th Titan shifter exists that out there
somewhere for quite a while but we only
learned the name of the final Titan
shifter back in Chapter 95 of the manga
a chapter that interestingly enough has
the title liar the reason that this
title is interesting is that we are told
by Zeke that the possessor of the
Warhammer Titan is the head of the Tiber
noble family Willy Tiber however the
first time we actually see the Warhammer
Titan is in chapter 101 of the manga and
this happens after Aaron rips Willy
Tiber apart and murders him at this
point it is revealed that the true
holder of the Warhammer Titan was not
Willy Tiber but rather his sister here
on the channel we deliberately held off
on making an entire video on the
Warhammer Titan after chapter 101
because we had a feeling that we would
learn a lot more about it in the next
chapter since the battle between the
Warhammer Titan and Aaron and the survey
Corps was just getting started and as
predicted we learned a lot more
information about the Warhammer Titan
and it's truly impressive powers in
Chapter 102 of the manga and I can't
wait to talk about it all right here in
this video if you enjoyed the attack on
titan content on this channel and you
want to see more be sure to leave a like
to let me know if you're new don't
forget to subscribe and hit that
notification bell and we are now posting
daily anime content on twitter and
instagram so feel free to follow us
at Anime uproar the Warhammer Titan has
been in the possession of a noble LD and
family known as the timers for many
generations and the Tiber family is
unique because despite being LD ins they
are treated with respect and allowed to
live freely in Marlay on top of that we
later learn from Willie Tiber that the
Tiber family are actually the secret
rulers of Marlay and I am sure that the
Warhammer tightened with its incredible
abilities constitutes a major factor in
how the timers were able to attain this
position when we first see the Warhammer
Titan appear after Aaron's attack on
Willie
Aaron's attacked Titan pounces right
away so we don't even get to see the
Warhammer Titans full transformation
until it uses its unique ability to
impale Aaron on a giant spike that seems
to shoot up from the ground when we
finally do see the Warhammer Titan it is
definitely an absolutely unique form
with a helmet like cover on its head
that includes straps across the eyes and
mouth the appearance of the Warhammer
Titan has been compared to the armor of
a medieval knight to an executioner and
even to the Grim Reaper the incredible
power of the Warhammer Titan has also
been compared to alchemy think of Edward
Elric from Full Metal Alchemist and this
is because the Warhammer Titan can
literally create weapons from its body
many Titan shifters have the ability to
harden their body or parts of their body
but the Warhammer Titan can use this
hardening power to produce weapons that
are not directly connected to its body
in chapter 102 Aaron states that he
believes that the Warhammer tines
ability to create weapons is directly
related to its hardening ability and
despite its name the Warhammer Titan can
generate a lot more than just a hammer
along with a hammer this Titan can
create a giant spike multiple smaller
spikes that it scatters across the
ground and a variety of other weapons
including a crossbow so not only can
this Titan use its ability to
materialize powerful short-range weapons
but it can actually create a weapon that
launches projectiles at long distance
and if these conventional weapons
weren't bad enough the Warhammer Titan
can launch a whole bunch of deadly
spikes at its opponent at the
same time essentially producing what
looks like a terrifying tree of
destruction by the way shout out to my
boy laws who had guessed about six
months ago that the war hammer tines
ability might be to produce various
tools or weapons during the battle
against the war hammer titan eren and
the survey corps realized that unlike
the other Titans the war hammer Titan
appears to be invulnerable to attacks
against its head and Nate Aaron then
remembers that when the body of the
Warhammer Titan first appeared it was
build up from the feet and not from its
name this leads to a pretty big twist as
we learned that the body of the shifter
is not located inside the Warhammer
Titan at all instead the body of Willie
Tiber sister is located inside a crystal
that looks exactly like the crystal that
Annie created for herself after she was
captured back on the island as the
Warhammer Tyne is fighting Eren in the
plaza the shifters body is inside the
crystal beneath the plaza and the
crystal is connected to the foot of the
Warhammer Titan through some sort of
cord Eren manages to grab the crystal
and rip off the cord connecting it to
the Warhammer Titan which makes the
Titans body collapse however Willy Tiber
sister is not frozen inside the crystal
on the contrary she remains conscious
inside the crystal and she is aware of
what's going on we see her open her eyes
inside the crystal and when she sees the
right opportunity she is able to
transform again and create a new Titan
body from inside the crystal this was a
huge reveal for me personally because
this means that Annie is most likely
still conscious and aware of what is
going on inside her crystal as well
annie is unable to transform at this
time because her crystal is being kept
underground but knowing what we know now
regarding Willie's sister it is safe to
assume that if Annie's crystal is moved
at some point and she sees the right
opportunity she could choose to trigger
another Titan transformation and use it
to escape from the survey Corps maybe
Annie has already made a move at some
point during the time skip and we just
don't know it yet I am certain that the
unique powers of the Warhammer Titan
have some sort of significance for any
situation and I can't wait to see where
the Annie story line goes from
here aside from the Warhammer Titans
incredible powers including generating
epic weapons of various shapes and sizes
being able to take damage to the nape
without being heard due to the fact that
the shifter is outside of the body and
having excellent stamina that allows the
shifter to create a new Titan as soon as
the core to the old one is severed the
Warhammer Titan likely has additional
advantages if the story that we've been
told so far is true and we cannot know
for sure because it is clear that Willie
has been lying about certain things but
if the Warhammer tyne really has been
within the same family for generations
then this would mean that the current
shifter Willie Tiber sister is able to
access the memories of the previous
shifters without problem when a Titan
shifter power is held within the same
family such as the Fritz Royal Family
the memories that the current shifters
can access are clearer than the memories
that a random person would have access
to if they had taken their Titan power
from someone they had no connection to
the other big question is whether the
Tiber family possesses royal blood
we know that shifters with royal blood
are more powerful and possess
extra abilities than shifters who do not
have royal blood
for example shifters with royal blood
have the ability to control mindless
Titans
but while the Tiber czar an LD and noble
family I know that many of you do not
think that they have royal blood like
the Fritz family does however personally
I do think that the Tiber and other LD
and noble families would have royal
blood the reason that I say this is that
if we look at empires and kingdoms
throughout history royal families always
intermarried with the noble families of
theirs or other kingdoms on the one hand
members of the royal family cannot just
marry each other because let's face it
being inbred for a long period of time
without diversifying their gene pool
would likely lead to severe genetic
abnormalities in their children on the
other hand the LD and royal family would
not accept mere commoners into their
ranks since historically almost all
royal families made a big deal out of
not marrying commoners so the only real
option for the Fritz family before they
moved to the island would have been to
marry their children to the children of
the LD and noble families I would
imagine that over the centuries some
members of
Tibor family would have married members
of the fritz family and vice-versa if
one of the LDN kings had an older son
and a younger daughter the son would
likely become the king and any woman he
married would become a fritz
but since the king still had another
child who wouldn't be the queen because
her brother was the king she would need
to marry a member of one of the noble
families and joined that noble family so
I can definitely see that in cases where
the King had multiple children some of
the children could have married into the
Tiber family and this would mean that at
the current point in history the tie
burrs also have royal blood one hint
that could point to this is the fact
that the Warhammer Titan is able to
speak in complete sentences while in its
Titan form whereas most Titans seem to
have trouble speaking just think of Amir
when she was in her jaw tighten form and
how her words came out when she spoke as
a Titan on the other hand the Titan that
speaks the most clearly and in the most
complete sentences is zeke Yeager's
beast Titan and of course we know that
Zeke has royal blood so this could be a
clue however we don't have enough
evidence to say for sure at this point
so at this time the idea that the Tiber
Sirois alot is just my theory personally
I can't wait to see what else the
Warhammer Titan has in store and I'm
looking forward to finding out more
about the Tiber family and their history
let me know what you guys think
do you like the Warhammer Titans power
and where do you think that the
Warhammer Titan ranks on the list of the
most powerful Titan shifters also let me
know whether you think that the Tiber
family has royal blood if you enjoy the
attack on titan videos on this channel
and you'd like to see more be sure to
leave a like to let me know if you are
new to the channel don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
be sure to join us on discord and twitch
where we're gonna be having parties to
celebrate the fact that we hit over
100,000 subscribers
it's crazy thank you all again and we
are also posting daily anime content on
Twitter and Instagram so feel free to
follow us there at anime uproar as
always thank you all so much for
watching thank you again for the
unbelievable support and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]
you
[Music]